once you have finished drinking the beer it tastes good is
my answer is always if
you like 37 degree warm beer you are
welcome to try it it is not poisonous but
it tastes bitter
my name is rose andrea and
we are here in the swimming pool
here in the Starkenberg brewery
powerful pair of guitars 10 tirol she
15 years ago this room was still part of
the breweries, the breweries were
remodeled
and our boss had the idea that we
could have a beer bath here
in the gardens of the brewery we
now offer our guests a beer swimming pool
so what should we do  one perceives is
natural because the smell of the pen and
the home and you are in the water it
is quite normal
like one of his ladies it is very good
for the skin gets a very fine
overall skin it is also
recommended not to shower afterwards because
it can then be absorbed into the skin among
its good care factor
yes i think the reasons why the people
in the  want to bathe in beer is that it is something
unique
it is not offered anywhere else in the world
not in this form not in this
size
if you book our beer bath you
can tap a beer you can
eat something here you can drink something here
you can have a lot of fun